[Music]  there are some moments  that haunt us all our lives  moments  upon which history turns  well hello my friend  what is this what have you done  welcome to the road  not  taken  do you have any idea what's happening  here  reality has been broken  there is a divergence  i know someone who could help us  understand the change in time  i'm gonna need some tea  earl grey  piping hot hello guymon  your answers are not in the stars and  they never have been  earth  2024  a single change  was vastly more dangerous than you  realize  none of our tomorrows are guaranteed  we're stronger together you must bring  us home  this is a very bumpy century  [Music]  but uh i think i'm getting the hang of  it  i believe  you have one final frontier